الان الى التطورات في روسيا حيث اعلن جهاز
امن الدوله الروسي الغاء التهامي الجنائيه
المتعلقه بالتمرد المسلح لمجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه وذكرت وكاله نوفوستي نقلا عن
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان مجموعه تستعد
لتسليم عتادها العسكري للوزاره من جههها
ذكرت وكاله رويترز ان طائره تابعه لقائد
مجموعه
انطلقت من روسيا متجهه الى جارتها
بيلاروسيا
هذا وقالت الرئاسه الروسيه ان حل ازمه
التمرد يعود بشكل اساسي لجهود الرئيس
بوتين وارادته في منع تطور الاحداث نحو
السيناريو الاسوا واكد الكريملين ان
التفاف المجتمع الروسي حول بوتين في اعلى
مستوياته واشار الى ان بوتين سيتوجه اليوم
بكلمه الى وحدات هيئات انفاذ القانون التي
ضبطت النظام اثناء التمرد
معنا من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي
رانيا هل حملت كلمه بوتين امام هيئه انفاذ
القانون اي جديد بخصوص قضيه فاغنر ومن
جديد عموما في هذه القضيه
بدايه سهام لابد من الاشاره الى ان
تصريحات بوتين خطابه اليوم امام
هيئات انفاذ القانون لم تتطرق ابدا لموضوع
ومستقبل فاكتور كل ما تم التركيز عليه في
الخطاب هو ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه قد
تنفذت عملها بتثاني بحيث منعت وقوع حرب
اهليه في البلاد وايضا منعت سفك للدماء
على الارض في روسيا وان الشعب الروسي
والجيش الروسي في هذه المرحله الصعبه كان
قد وقف ضد التمرد المسلحه الذي شهدته
البلاد في الرابع والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري ولكن ادعيني سهام اشير الى تصريحات
في غايه الاهميه كانت قد صدرت تباعا عن
رئيس
الحرس الوطني الروسي الذي اشار الى عده
نقاط مهمه وهي فيما يتعلق بتحركات اليوم
اشار الى ان حرس الوطني كانت لديه معلومات
يعني تسريب للمعلومات عن امكانيه تنفيذ
تمرد مسلح على الارض في روسيا ما بين
25 من الشهر الجاري اشار الى ان انه في
هذه المرحله تم التركيز القوى بالدرجه
الاولى في العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها بسبب
التقدم السريع لقوات فاجنر نحو العاصمه
موسكو اشار الى ان اي وصول للعاصمه كان
سيتم قبعه بشكل جذري ولكن الاهم من ذلك
سهام هو اشارته الى ان الى ضلوع اجهزه
الاستخبارات الغربيه فيما حدث في موسكو في
الرابع والعشرين وهنا تحدث
ظواطف واشار الى ان الهيئات الامنيه
الاستخباراتيه الغربيه يعني كانت قد اشرفت
وحضرت لهذا التمرد كونها كانت على علم
بوقوعه قبل ايام ولم يستبعد ايضا مشاركه
هذه الهيئات على الارض في عمليه التمرد
المسلح حسب تعبيرهم بشكل عام فيما يتعلق
بمستقبل فاجن الاشاره الى ايضا في تصريحات
كانت قد صدرت عن الكرملين في وقت سابق
الذي اكد ان الاراده اراده الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لمنع سيناريوهات اكثر
دمويه واكثر ماساويه والضمانات التي قدمها
لقوات فاجنر كل ذلك حاله دون وقوع هذه
الحرب الاهليه وسفك الدماء على الارض في
روسيا وهنا الحديث يدور عن الضمانات التي
قدمها بوتين بالنسبه لشركه باغنر والاسيمه
لمالكها
هنا اود التذكير بانه تم التوافق على سحب
القوات قوات باغينر من الارض وعدم
ملاحقتها القانونيه ورفع القضيه الجنائيه
بحق بريجوجل مقابل الانسحاب وقف التمرد
ومغادرته نحو الاراضي البيلاروسيه اذا
روسيا في هذه المرحله الحساسه تتحدث عن
تدخلات غربيه تتحدث عن ان مصير يعني فاغنر
حتى هذه اللحظه سهام يمكن القول انه ليس
واضح بشكل كامل هناك العمل يجري حاليا على
الصعيد القانوني لمعرفه الكيفيه التي سيتم
تنظيم فيها عمل الشركات الخاصه على الارض
في روسيا في المستقبل وهناك ثلاث خيارات
اودد الاشاره الى ان وفقا لتصريحات بوتين
ليله خيارات امام هذه القوات وهي اولا اما
توقيع عقود مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه او
العوده لمنازلها والخيار الثالث هو
الانتقال نحو الاراضي البيلاروسيه شكرا